[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today all right
today's question comes from Terry in
Maryland my husband and I have a HELOC
with an adjustable rate it started at
3.5 last year and now it's at 8.5
percent we owe 57 000 and our current
monthly payment is approximately 750
dollars we began paying an extra 500
toward it a month however this impacts
our lifestyle an ability to do the
things that we love such as travel
frequently as well as other Home
Improvements
total owed with HELOC and mortgage is
about 429 000 are household income is
275 000.
our only other debt is about payment
that we also make extra monthly payments
on
I'm trying to do my best here Dave is it
best to continue paying extra on the
current HELOC and hope the rates drop or
a find a loan with a lower fixed rate uh
fixed interest rate which may end up
being higher than the adjustable rate in
the future our goal is to pay this off
ASAP yet the eight percent makes this
difficult by the way my credit score is
800 plus
this is not be gentle this is not a long
time listener no this is not a long time
long time listeners don't close with
their credit score that's a good point
unless it's zero
Dave thank you Dave because you you gave
you gave Grace and now I shouldn't I was
making fun of them all the way through
the whole email but there you go
Grace okay
listener or a an early listener to us
um you've gotten yourself in a mess
the good news is you've got a great
great great great income to get yourself
out of this mess
um I probably would not move the HELOC
for now
um I'd keep it right where it's at what
I would do if I were you
um is I would start working our plan
you're you've obviously found us you
trust us enough to write us a letter
right so I'd start working through this
um I live I I want to know more about
them Dave but I try to bust that income
down to living on about a hundred
thousand a year and I'd be taking the
majority of it 175 000 a year paying off
this debt and I'd probably be trying to
be debt free house in all one year
pay off the HELOC of fifty seven
thousand pay off the boat we don't know
how much the boat is but pay them both
off in one year for God's sakes you make
275 000 freaking dollars a year yeah
your mortgage could be gone in two and a
half years hey they might not be able to
listen I'm listen you you one of the
things I had to do
was
in order to get out in order to stop
being broke was I had to stop the
whining yeah that's so real I can so
whine to myself about how I work so hard
I'm entitled I and my wife would look at
me and say yeah show this everyone
call the wambulance I love Sharon
oh she's tough she's great she's mean
she's hateful and stuff like that no
she's crazy bust your bubble man
so I had to learn to talk to myself
Terry so I'm going to talk to you that
way call the wambulance about your
little travel plans yeah you have a
freaking boat you didn't even pay for
there's your travel plan so go out on
the boat since you already have it
that's your travel plan that's it you
can't do anything else you're not
allowed to leave because you have to pay
off your debt in one year 57 000 plus
the debt minus 275 is still a lot of
freaking money no whining Allowed no
whining it's going to go buy this stuff
we're trying to figure out a way to
interest rate trick yourself into
spending more than you make Congress has
tried it for years and it just doesn't
work
let's talk about the credit score
okay
why not why not because I to close with
that oh and by the way my credit score
is 800 plus all that indicates to me all
that indicates mathematically is that
they possibly plan on using that credit
score more in the future oh if you're
touting that that lets me know okay this
matters to you you want it to be right
so that possibly in the future you can
use it again there's only one way to get
an 800 credit score
only one way what's that Dave borrow a
lot of money
and pay a lot of interest when you pay
it all back on time
and that's the only way this this means
you have been playing make out with the
bank in the back seat of the car that's
what the credit score means okay it
means you've been playing kissy face
with the bank that's all it means it
does not mean you have a net worth it
does not mean you have an income it
doesn't mean you have nothing but you've
been kissing the bank all the time and
the bank is a butterface
you know what that is no
I can't talk about this yeah good just
keep it there it means everything looks
good but their face oh I got you I got
you so now I understand the bank the
bank is hiding the true yeah yeah
they all look good at closing time okay
um so there we go yeah oh my gosh oh my
gosh here we go
credit score is 100 derived by your
interaction with debt so bragging about
your credit scores like I love debt I
love debt I love debt that's why Jade is
saying she thinks you're going to go
back in debt again so if you want to do
the stuff we teach which is designed to
get you into wealth and peace as fast as
possible the shortest right way then
what you'd have to do is
get yourself out of debt and limit your
lifestyle to do that and so this is
about growing up
it's about adulting children do what
feels good adults devise a plan and
follow it so don't be playing kissy face
with the bank anymore you're not going
to borrow your way out of this you're
going to pay your way out of it thank
God you have a fabulous household income
and you don't have a lot of debt but you
do have a lot of symptoms of somebody
who's getting ready to make a huge mess
that's right I mean we just heard a
debt-free scream making thirty six
thousand they paid off 80 000 making
thirty six thousand yeah and it took
five years of sacrifice you've got maybe
12 months maybe yeah we don't know how
big the boat is you know yeah that's
true we don't know how big a boat is at
least here we go there we go that's it
the uh
that segment will go down in infamy